[Music]
Emma Watson was the belle of the ball at
the London premiere of Beauty and the
Beast now everything about this movie is
spectacular in fact just love this
28,000 square foot village they built
for shooting pretty amazing only we can
show you how they brought Belle July 25
years after the animated classic
[Music]
the same rule bred animals to stop
beating the Beast really if you think
about it is like for movies in one it's
an action movie it's also a comedy you
are the one gorgeous thing I've ever
seen nobody deserves then on the other
hand it's a romance and then it's a
musical actually turned down Emma
Stone's role in la-la-land to focus on
this film coincidentally while the lands
Ryan Gosling was considered for the
beast for the role eventually went to
Downton Abbey's Dan Stevens and unlike
in the original movie we get to see the
beast as a prince before he was cursed
wonderful book you have that Luke Evans
wore fake teeth to play the arrogant
guest on Josh GAD as his sidekick Lefou
Emma Thompson voices mrs. Potts Sir Ian
McKellen is Cogsworth Ewan McGregor is
Lumiere and Audra McDonald is the or moi
do not be alarmed members L this is just
your wardrobe and speaking of wardrobe
while the yellow gown worn by Bell in
this iconic ballroom scene took 12,000
hours to create we wanted the dress to
feel like it could float and despite
months of practice imitation is still
nervous to dance with Dan who were
stilts to be the height of the beast how
do you do a three minute waltz routine
with a beast I mean he's like three
heads taller than me
you
[Music]